هذه الزيارة من قبل السيد.  لقد قام الرئيس
بتعزيز هذه العلاقة أكثر ،
أعتقد أن مشاركة القطاع الخاص
تستجيب لإحدى
مبادراتنا الرئيسية ، وبالتالي فإن
فكرة مشاركة القطاع الخاص
تنمو LGTB من حيث وصلت الآن إلى 65٪ ،
وهذا من الرؤساء التنفيذيين.  من الواضح أنها
إحدى الطرق لعرض الفرص
يوم السبت في النهاية ، لدينا الكثير من
الفرص التي يمكن للشركات الأمريكية الاستفادة منها ،
لقد سمعنا عن صفقات أسلحة بقيمة مائة مليار دولار
على الأقل أربعين مليار
دولار في الإنفاق على البنية التحتية ، ولكن
هناك الكثير من الفرص لكليهما  الطرق التي
تدخل بها الأموال الأمريكية إلى الاقتصاد السعودي للمساعدة
في خطة 2030 ، ستكون هناك
استثمارات كبيرة من السعودية في الولايات المتحدة ، ولكن
ستكون هناك أيضًا فوائد
كبيرة للراتب حيث سيكون هناك فرص عمل ،
وكان هناك استثمارات على كلا
الجانبين وسترى ذلك  عندما
يتم الإعلان عن الصفقات وفي غضون يومين عندما
تكون هناك استثمارات
كبيرة في كلا الجانبين ، قمت بإجراء تغيير جذري في السياسة
من خلال إعادة تثبيت  تخفيضات رواتب الموظفين
الحكوميين بنسبة 20٪ هل كان ذلك
ضعفًا أم حكيمة من العالم الخارجي
بدا وكأنه ضعف - هذا في
الواقع سؤال مثير للاهتمام للغاية
ما قمنا به خلال الأشهر الثمانية عشر
الماضية إصلاحات مهمة الكثير من
الإصلاحات بما في ذلك أحدها
بدلات الموظفين وقد تم
ذلك في وقت كنا
قلقين بشأنه حقًا على الرغم من أنني تقدمت بطلب للحصول عليها
قلقًا بشأن ضغوط أخرى مختلفة
في الاقتصاد ، قرر الملك أنه ربما
حان الوقت أثناء ضخ المزيد من
التمويل في أيدي الناس بحيث
من شأنه أن يساعد الاقتصاد على النمو
أكثر ، أخبرني عن ضريبة الإنتاج أو
ضريبة الخطيئة على منتجات التبغ ، على سبيل المثال ،
حتى ضريبة على السعوديين غير المقيمين على
الدخل الذي ننقله مع صديقنا
وشقيقنا من دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وسنقوم
بتطبيق المكوس  لكن ضريبة دخل غير المقيمين
ستكون ثورية كما
تعلم بالنسبة للمنطقة ، فنحن نسمح
بإدخال أي ضريبة دخل غير مقيم
على الإطلاق وليس حتى عام 2020 أو ما بعده.
استمعت إلى خفض ضريبة الدخل
وقام موظفونا بتطوير
ضريبة الدخل ونفقات السكان إذا
كنا لا نزال نجري محادثة في
عام 2020 حول 50 أو 55 دولارًا من النفط في المملكة
العربية السعودية حيث فشلت الخطة ،
فلن نهتم كثيرًا بما إذا كان
السعر 40 45  50 55 في ذلك الوقت ،
نخطط للتخلي عن
التبعية التي كنا نعيشها
طوال الأربعين 50 عامًا الماضية ، ونأمل أنه
بحلول 30 2013 لن أهتم بالبيع
والأسعار صفر على الرغم من أنني أود أن
تكون مائة و  خمسين رأينا
ارتفاعًا في أسعار الطاقة المائية التي تعمل بالبنزين ، حيث إن
الشعب السعودي مستعد حقًا
للالتزام بخطة ولي ولي العهد
، فهم يدركون أن ارتفاع الإيرادات
مع تقلب الأسعار لا يمكن أن يكون
وسيلة مستدامة لدعم
الاقتصاد.  نحتاج حقًا إلى سعودية
تتصرف مثل قادة العالم العربي والإسلامي ،
فنحن قلب
الاتصال العربي ونحتاج إلى الاستفادة
من كل ذلك لتعزيز اقتصادنا
وجعله محاربًا.  نجعل شعبنا يعيش
حياة أفضل